Here's my answer.
We'll go diagonal by diagonal.
The first one is easy since it's just
the cost of the pairwise product.
Next we'll consider this entry here
corresponding to the product of ABC.
First, consider breaking it up as A(BC).
That would be 0 for computing A,
+ 9 for computing C,
+ 6 x 3 x 3 for computing the product,
for a total of 63.
The other partition, (A B) x C,
has cost 18 for (A B).
0 for C and 6 x1 x 3 for
combining the products,
for a total of 36.
That ends up as the smaller of the two
possibilities, so we'll go ahead and
write that information
in the table here.
Now we move on to the other entry
along this diagonal, the one for
the product BCD.
We'll consider first
computing this as B(CD).
That costs 0 for B, 24 for CD, and
for computing the product,
3 x 1 x 8, for a total of 48.
The other partition,
BC x D, has cost 9 for
BC, 0 for just grabbing D and
3 x 3 x 8 for the product,
for a total 82.
48 is the minimum cost and the better
partition is B x the quantity CD.
So, we'll record that
information in the table.
Now, for the last entry.
Consider first the partition
A x the quantity BCD.
The cost of A by itself is 0.
The cost of BCD, was 48 and
the cost of the product was 6
x 3 x 8 for a total of 192.
The products AB x CD costs 18 for
AB, 24 for CD, and
6 x 1 x 8 for combining these
products for a total of 90.
Lastly, we have this partition
the quantity ABC x D.
ABC cost 36, D by itself costs 0,
and the product costs 6 x 3 x 8 for
a total of 180.
The middle one here is clearly the best,
so we record that fact, and
that gives us the partition, which we
can write in these squares like so.